welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the shining stanley kubrick's
1980 horror masterpiece based on stephen
king's 1977 novel has
shined its chilling influence through
nearly every successive film and tv
series of our lives
both in horror genres and even scarier
places like the pixar
universe the shining's lingering
mysteries have made it one of the most
overanalyzed films of
all time there is even a documentary
about conspiracy theory interpretations
that make new rock stars theory sound
like occam's very rational razor
let us dive deep into the shining point
out all the subtle evidence for the
various interpretations of the film's
hidden meanings and
details that are only now being spotted
okay the film opens with jack torrance
jack nicholson as he drives to the
overlook hotel for his interview
these aerial shots of glacier national
park were actually later repurposed for
the reshot ending
of ridley scott's blade runner but it's
the music here that renders all these
beautiful landscapes
so frightening the main shining theme
was composed by wendy carlos and rachel
elkind adapting a traditional gregorian
chant called
ds irae which translates to day of wrath
and it was used for funerals
[Music]
so the reason that we're so on edge here
is that the music is prepping
us for a funeral in which a higher power
will decide whether we will end up in
heaven or trapped in hell
mixed in with this music is a doom
inspired soundscape
mixed by music editor gordon stanford
[Applause]
yeah you hear voices shriek and echo
like warnings from the past
many have interpreted the shining as a
metaphor for the human history of
violence and genocide
continuing to haunt our unconscious
psyche
until it eventually catches up to us so
we arrive at the overlook hotel the
exterior of which was based on the
timberline lodge and fort hood organ
though kubrick recreated it as a set at
all street studios in england you may
have noticed that he condensed the
recreated exterior to exclude the
timberline's pointed tower one of many
examples of the overlook's famous
impossible architecture as if this place
is a deceptive maze
an illogical death trap now stephen king
got the idea for his shiny novel
after he and his family stayed in the
stanley hotel in estes park
colorado they were the final guests
before it shut down for the winter and
king saw a group of nuns leaving the
hotel and started to wonder if the place
was godless as i'm sure he wonders about
every place he enters but notice in this
wide shot that there are exactly
42 cars in the parking lot now the
number 42 also shows up later on danny's
bugs bunny shirt
and later when they watch a tv a tv that
has no power cord by the way
they watched the movie the summer of 42.
some point to this recurring number 42
as evidence
that this movie could actually be about
the holocaust
since hitler's final solution was
ordered in 1942 there's also a huge
influence on jack's typewriter being a
german adler brand and typewriters being
assembled the nazi's obsessive
documentation of their war crimes
these folks have also argued that the
final cross dissolve on the photo of
jack leaves a brief superimposition of
his hairline on his upper lip
to create the illusion of a hitler
mustache which you could interpret as an
homage to hitchcock's famous
superimposition of mrs bates skull
on norman's face in the final shot of
psycho now that photograph is
actually right behind jack as he first
enters overlook lobby
we just overlooked it this is the first
of many smooth tracking shots that
kubrick accomplished with a steadicam
one of the first prominent uses of the
device
kubrick never cuts here and it leads to
this unsettling feeling as jack rounds
the corner
into omen's office notice that window if
you were to
map the layout of the hotel the window
in allman's office is considered an
impossible window because oman's office
should be in the building interior
there's no courtyard behind that room
it's actually implied that the building
goes way deeper and that's just one of
many visual curiosities in this shot
there's also this native american
painting on the outside the office
this is called the great mother by
artist norval morseau
when asked about this painting kubrick
said that every face that surrounds jack
here
is an archetype and that connects to the
book visible on allman's desk there
this is the red book of carl young young
being the famous psychoanalyst known for
his writings about the collective
unconscious and archetypes
young defied archetypes as universal
symbols that all human beings innately
associate collective meanings to
the mother is one of the most famous
archetypes so you can use these easter
eggs as a kind of road map
with which to analyze the rest of this
film which is a collection of meaningful
symbols that hit us
on a subconscious level you'll notice
that there are native american
references throughout the overlook
are all these indian designs authentic
yeah i believe
based mainly on navajo and uh apache
motifs
the site is supposed to be located on an
indian burial ground and i believe they
actually had to repel a few indian
attacks as they were building it
many believe that these references
symbolize the shining's deeper meaning
as a parable about white violence toward
indigenous peoples with the blood from
the elevators
actually coming from the graves of the
native americans buried underneath
white man's burden lloyd my man
white man's burden so olman tells jack
about a winter caretaker in the past
named charles grady who murdered his
wife and daughters due to what they
believed at the time to be cabin fever
but jack is weirdly unphased well you
can rest assured mr ullman that's not
gonna happen with me
yeah you'll notice that jack already
seems a bit unhinged here and that's a
credit to jack nicholson's impressive
performance
nicholson's casting was a major point of
contention from stephen king who
famously
hated the film adaptation of his novel
so king based jack torrance in the novel
on himself
a struggling writer who has sudden
terrifying thoughts of murdering his
kids
and bought through substance abuse to
him jack's transformation is so scary
because jack starts as a relatable every
man how king viewed himself but then he
fell victim to external supernatural
forces king saw nicholson as an actor
famous for playing unhinged characters
like in one flew over the cuckoo's nest
but this was kubrick's primary diversion
from king's text
kubrick said in an interview that jack
comes to the hotel psychologically
prepared to do its murderous bidding he
doesn't have very much further to go for
his unhinged frustration to become
completely uncontrollable he's bitter
about his failures as a writer he's
married to a woman for whom he is only
contempt
he hates his son and the hotel at the
mercy of its powerful evil he is quickly
ready to fulfill his dark role
i'm hungry
[Music]
why you should have eaten your breakfast
kubrick elaborated there's something
inherently wrong with the human
personality
there's an evil side to it one of the
things that horror stories can do is
show us the archetypes of the
unconscious we can see the dark side
without having to confront it directly
so olman also tells jack that they're
going to have to keep the hotel's boiler
running during the winter and this
detail relates to another major
difference in the book which ends with
the overlooked burning down
after the boiler explodes and the cycle
of violence
ending as opposed to kubrick's ending
which keeps that cycle going and going
and going meanwhile jack's wife wendy
shelley duvall and son danny danny lloyd
wait back in their home in boulder
when he reads the catcher in the rye a
book with its own links to various
conspiracies associated with john
hinckley jr and mark david chapman
though it should be noted reagan and
lennon were shot after the shining came
out
and we meet dany's imaginary friend tony
what about tony
he's looking forward to the hotel i bet
so in the novel tony is actually danny's
adult self speaking to him from the
future
since danny's middle name is anthony
tony for shorts but there is a
much darker theory about who tony is now
the next shot we see of dany he is
framed in the doorway to his bathroom
brushing his teeth he asks tony to tell
him why he doesn't want to go to the
hotel
danny suddenly struck with a vision of
the blood elevator the grady twins
and himself screaming the moment
halloran gets killed this leads to danny
suffering a panic attack and getting
examined by a doctor
who asks who tony is a little bit is in
my mouth
if you were to open your mouth now could
i see tony
no why not because he hides
where does he go to my stomach so
notice here that danny is also lying on
this bear pillow
his pants are off and he's covering
himself later in danny's bedroom at the
overlook there's a painting of
two bears over his bed one sitting one
standing a detail by the way that pops
up at time code 2237 the movie goes
inside
room 237 two times and wendy runs over a
bare rug
in between those two visits why am i
mentioning all this bear stuff well
there is a theory that dan
is connected to the man in the bear
costume shortly after this checkup wendy
tells the doctor that danny dislocated
his shoulder
five months prior because jack had been
drinking and grabbed danny away from
scattering his papers across the floor
so we are looking at a history of child
abuse so again that wtf moment the
mysterious bear costume ghost giving
oral sex to the older man
seen later by wendy in the final
sequence the theory is that jack
has sexually abused dany and that dany
represents the man in the bear costume
both are seen partially nude both are
framed the same way
in key moments huni in this case would
be jax
you know jack yuck i know i know i will
explain more of this dark interpretation
as it pertains to the way
room 237 is depicted but before we move
on notice that as wendy and the doctor
leave danny's bedroom
the dopey sticker that was once on the
door is now
missing now there are many interpreters
in the camp that kubrick is a master
filmmaker who makes no mistakes in this
film everything's intentional if you're
in that camp you could read this as a
kind of
loss of innocence for dany now aware of
the violent horrors that await him
thanks to the vision he's no longer a
dopey kid in fact his nickname is
another dwarf
doc which is actually for bugs money but
if you think about it in snow white and
seven doors doc
is also like the most awakened aware
haunted of that punch
he's always got that thousand-yard stare
anyway the whole family heads up to the
overlook and jack when he's sitting in
the lobby
reads a magazine pet if you look closely
is a play girl the january 1978 issue
which includes the article incest why
parents
sleep with their children another clue
that many point to evidence for jack's
sexual appetite which we see as he
checks out other guests
and possible sexual abuse of dany an in
sexual relationship because why else
would the set dresser put a freaking
play girl in a lobby of a hotel now
trailing behind olman is bill watson the
summer caretaker he's very limited
dialogue but when he does he seems a bit
on edge bill would you have the
torrance's things brought to their
apartments
fine i better collect my family first
yikes bill's having a day
this could be another hint that past
caretakers do not take well to this
hotel bill is super eager to leave now
in the game room danny gets his first
visit from the grady twins
now let's look at this shot there's one
interpretation that is pointed to that
monarch skiing poster
suggesting that the silhouetted skier
actually looks very much like
a minotaur as a metaphor for jack being
the minotaur monster of the greek myth
of the labyrinth
the reason why a lot of people believe
this is that the hedge maze was famously
a detail
not in king's novel kubrick created it
originally for this film and there are
several clues throughout this film that
established the exterior maze as a
duplicate of the interior maze of the
hotel itself yeah this whole place is
such an enormous maze i feel like i'll
have to leave a trail of breadcrumbs
every time i come in
and both of those mazes reflect the even
deeper maze of jack's
sanity so getting lost in a maze
represents losing one's sense of self
this mind maze metaphor has come up
again and again since the shining and
things like inception
westworld jordan peels us ultimately
danny's ability to retrace his steps
represents his ability to navigate his
own mind keep himself from going insane
you could also argue it reflects his
respect for the past
something that his psychic knowledge of
gave him an advantage to
save himself from his father's insanity
halloran talks to danny about their
shared telepathic abilities which he
calls
shining now stephen king came up with
the term shining from john lennon's song
instant karma
the idea being that all human souls
leave a trace in a historical record
behind you know
doc when something happens it can leave
a trace of
itself behind
say like if someone burns
toast well maybe things that happen
the other kind of traces behind
so even if interpretations of the
shining as a story about the holocaust
or the genocide of the native americans
weren't explicit on a broader thematic
level
this is a movie about the corruptive
power of past violence
on the fragile collective unconscious of
each of our inner demons now kubrick
works in some fun visual foreshadowing
in this moment
are you scared of this place
no for the first time after several
minutes in the scene
kubrick cuts too wide revealing the
knives on the column right over danny's
head
the same knife that wendy will later use
to defend them from jack and that danny
picks up in the bedroom so the shine is
answering danny's question in this
moment so danny
asks about room 237 hallerin warns him
to stay out and a month later we see
danny driving his big wheel on the
ground floor of the overlook
this is the first ever use of a low
angle steadicam they did this so
danny's big wheel would explode with
sound whenever he went over wood and
then go abruptly eerily silent whenever
he went over carpet
[Music]
danny rides a total of three times in
this movie analysts have mapped out the
route of the hotel's geography
each time he rides on a different floor
and when he rounds corners
there's nothing there the second time on
the second floor kubrick includes shots
of the second floor railing overlooking
the colorado lounge just to give you a
sense of how these two routes connect
but for the third big wheel ride later
in the movie kubrick uses those simple
expectations that he's set to now trick
us
danny rides through the kitchen but as
he rounds the corner he suddenly
teleports he's now pedaling
on the upper level by the family suite
and now when he rounds the corner who
knows what we'll see
oh [ __ ] it's the grady twins but more on
that later so wendy brings jack
breakfast in bed and we initially see
jack sleeping but it's through a mirror
it's a misdirect by kubrick jack isn't
the important element in the shot
the mirror is it is this mirror that
wendy will later see
red rum turning into murder and it has a
deeper special meaning that i will get
to but in this shot we stay on the image
of jack through the mirror his shirt
says
stovington which in king's novel is the
name of the high school that jack
teaches at
when i came up here for my interview
it was as though i'd been here before
it was almost as though i knew what was
going to be around
every corner yeah there's a lot of
foreshadowing going on here
danny and wendy get surprised by ghosts
jumping out at them from behind corners
in this film
but not jack and from halloran's
perspective later jack is the demonic
presence popping out from behind the
corner and that is because
as we see in the final shot jack was
destined to be a part of the horror of
the overlook
he has always been there so as jack's
writer's block sets in
wendy and danny play in the hedge maze
the camera follows them as they round
corners and then we cross dissolve
to jack now kubrick uses long cross
dissolves throughout this film creates
all kinds of interesting super
impositions
but this one is my favorite because for
a moment jack's
large form is superimposed over wendy
and dany
as if he is stalking them through the
maze just as he will for danny later on
kubrick underlines jack's predatory
posture by having jack looming over the
miniature maze
we cut from jack looking down over it
with a wolf-like grin or a minotaur
light grin i guess two an overhead shot
of danny and wendy tiny in the center of
the maze as if jack is a giant having
trapped them inside now the maze built
for the movie was not this large or
elaborate kubrick filmed wendy and danny
from overhead but then edited this so
that the central part of the maze would
be lifted out
and then placed into a scale model of
the maze so
just as jack's imagination is doing
kubrick used a visual effect
to shrink them to fit inside jack's mind
so the second time danny writes his big
wheel he passes room 237 now this second
floor hexagonal carpet pattern is now
infamous in production design the pixar
animators used it in hallway carpet for
sid's house it also recently showed
up on the back of the kid's skateboard
in chapter 2. so wendy checks in on jack
who's typing away
we later learned that he's just typing
the phrase all work and no play make
jacket doughboy over and over and over
again
suggesting that even in this moment this
guy has already completely snapped now
notice the scrapbook on the table beside
him
this was left over from a deleted scene
in which jack found this scrapbook in
the basement
chronicling events from the hotel's dark
past with photographs setting up the
final image photograph in the novel the
scrapbook is a much bigger plot point
the overlook struggles trying to possess
danny
so it moves on to jack feeding on his
writer's block and enticing him with the
rich history of the hotel
via the scrapbook so jack cruelly cusses
out wendy but notice the chair behind
him
it is there at first then we cut to
windy then back to jack
and the chair is gone and then it
reappears the next time we cut back to
jack
now again assuming kubrick never makes
any mistakes this could reflect
jack's insanity like when he played with
the ball earlier there was no chair
pulled up to the table because think
about the camera was in place where the
chair would have been
the chair back against the wall means
that it's not at the table because jack
isn't riding it was still pulled back
against the wall
jack's mind keeps mentally projecting
the chair pulled away from the table
because he knows he is not actually
progressing on his book jack later
watches wendy and danny play in the snow
giving them this murderous look kubrick
loves his expression
downward tilt eyes up mouth hung open a
kind of a drooling smile it's the same
exact base that private
pyle made and full metal jacket it's
this soulless animalistic glare
okay so jumping ahead danny rounds the
corner to find the grady twins
come and play with us daddy
forever and ever
and ever
[Music]
yeah i know it messed me up too the
grady twins have been paid homage in a
ton of films
one recent example was jordan peels us
the twins of that movie were slaughtered
and posed in the same exact way as the
grady twins were now the next day dany
runs into jack and they're sweet jack is
framed in the mirror
again staring creepily at dany now
remember this shot and he tells danny to
sit with him this interaction just feels
so uncomfortable the music makes it seem
like something could go wrong at any
moment
dad yes
you feel bad
[Music]
ah
just a little bit tired
[Music]
then why don't you go to sleep
[Music]
i can't i got too much to do
now stephen king's sequel to the shining
is called dr sleep it's been adapted
into a 2019 film with ewan mcgregor as
an adult
danny torrance in that danny uses his
shine as a hospice nurse helping people
go to sleep perhaps it all started in
this moment danny thinking if his father
could just sleep
nothing bad would have happened i wish
we could stay here
forever ever
ever yeah you probably noticed jack is
echoing the grady twins who also wanted
danny to play with them in the hotel
forever and ever
and we never see the end of this scene
leaving things open-ended for a lot of
the theories that we have discussed
because the immediate next scene is one
of the most scrutinized sequences in all
of cinema
a close-up shows danny playing with his
cars when a tennis ball
rolls up perfectly down the line of the
carpet pattern but then as he stands
notice two things
one the carpet pattern has suddenly
changed the vertical line is now behind
him
danny was using this pattern as roadways
for his cars
now the path before him has been closed
off trapping him
and two his sweater the apollo 11 rocket
now one of the more out there
interpretations of the shining that i
really don't buy is that the movie is
secretly kubrick expressing his inner
breakdown
over the theory that he helped the us
government fake the apollo 11
moon landing there are some conspiracy
theories out there who believe that the
film 2001 a space odyssey was kubrick
actually conducting a research project
for what would be a film recording of
the lunar surface on a
sound stage they point to what they
claim our flaws in that footage and that
either the americans did go to the moon
and the footage was just faked or that
we never went to the moon at all look
there's a lot of thought diversity among
the tin foil community they point to the
fact that kubrick changed the room
number from
217 as it was in king's novel to 237.
the production said it was because the
real life hotel asked him to change it
so that people wouldn't be afraid to
stay in that room conspiracy there is
claim that he changed it because the
moon
is 237 000 miles from earth it is not
it is actually 238 855 miles but you
know whatever they also point to the
hexagonal pattern matching the design of
the nasa launch pad site
and they say that there's tang visible
in the pantry and that jack's odd rant
to wendy about having to honor his
contract might be a secret cry for help
from kubrick having to honor his
contract
does it matter to you at all that the
owners have placed their complete
confidence and trust in me and that i
have signed a letter of agreement
a contract in which i have accepted that
responsibility
has it ever occurred to you what would
happen to my future
if i were to fail live up to my
responsibilities really i think there
are interpretations of what happened in
room 237 with a bit more evidence
connected to the overall themes of the
story
really i am interested in the theory
that i have discussed and been disgusted
in that this room is all about sex and
sexual violence
now let's break this down we never see
the room from danny's perspective he
just walks in through the door though
the scene
transitions too wendy checking the
electrical equipment downstairs and if
you look closely that area
is covered in hardcore pornographic
images you might not have noticed these
any other times you've watched this
movie but they are there and the reason
we don't notice them is because wendy
doesn't react to them at all it's almost
as if she doesn't see them
as if those along with that playgirl
down the lobby and that room 237 women
are all ghostly perversions
that she cannot see yet wendy finds jack
screaming from a nightmare
i dreamed that i killed you with danny
[Music]
but then danny approaches his sweater
torn his neck bruised
sucking his thumb wendy asked him what
happened
and he does not answer though kubrick
frames jack in the background between
them and as wendy accuses jack
of another round of child abuse she
picks up danny and notice that danny's
limbs are frozen
apparently kubrick swapped out the actor
danny lloyd with a mannequin
so that this young actor wouldn't be
exposed to the truly dark subject matter
of this movie
so jack heads to the gold room and
notice he angrily spasms a few times as
he walks down the hallway and he only
does this
after he passes each mirror again we are
seeing how mirrors
are exposing a truth about the inner
darkness of this film
and that mirror device continues into
the gold room where jack sits down at an
empty bar then he makes a kind of deal
with the devil
[Music]
right in this moment jack looks into the
mirror on the bar's back wall kubrick
has moved the camera
so that we are now the focus of his gaze
it is
so unnerving to have jack look down the
barrel of the lens like this normally in
films it's a mistake
here jack breaks the glass of the fourth
wall and the movie
now shifts inside jack's unstable mind
and the evil forces of the hotel
have granted his wish a fully stocked
bar
and a bartender lloyd who never makes
jack pay for his drinks
because jack is paying for this with his
soul jack tells lloyd
just a little problem with the uh old
sperm bank
upstairs now it is assumed by sperm bank
he is talking about wendy but
a few seconds later jack abruptly
transitions to
danny i never laid a hand on him god
damn it
i didn't but then he admits he did
exactly that
i didn't hurt him once okay but he
claims it was an accident
a rage motivated accident my little
[ __ ] thrown all my papers all over the
floor all i tried to do was pull him up
but then wendy runs in screaming with a
bat and lloyd is gone the bar
empty because she cannot yet perceive
what jack perceives
she tried to straighten all danny
are you out of your [ __ ] mind now it
doesn't make sense that the room 237
woman could have physically hurt danny
halloran said the ghosts weren't real
just pictures in a book so even if the
hotel is haunted
the ghosts should only be visions that
drive the human inhabitants to hurt each
other
so either danny must have given himself
the bruises as jack said
or more likely jack heard him we never
see jack
enter room 237 we actually enter it
through the perspective of halloran
dining into the hotel from miami
initially halloran's vision is from a
low angle the angle of dany's height as
he first entered the room but then after
showing danny shining to him
drooling we return to a point of view
shot
inside room 237 but we're now at a
higher angle that floats around the room
until we realize we are now seeing this
from jack's perspective so what does
this all mean
well one interpretation is that there is
no room 237
that the room is just a dreamed
recreation of a memory when jack
sexually abused danny there is some
interesting evidence for this
notice that the outline on the bathroom
floor matches
exactly the shape of the mirror through
which jack can be seen
leering at danny earlier also the
gesture that the woman in the tub
makes to jack matches the gesture that
jack makes to danny earlier on which was
remember a creepy scene that we never
saw the end of some also see
phallus shapes in the purple and green
carpeting i don't know about that but
there is a noticeable
head turn that glances at the bed in
room 237
that matches jack's earlier neck crane
into danny's room to look at his bed i
believe that room 237
does exist mainly because wendy knows
about it and this is before the
invisible becomes visible to wendy in
the hotel
i believe kubrick's interpretive editing
could suggest that jack
and danny were in this room together 237
is larger than the other rooms in that
hall it has double doors compared to the
single doors of the neighboring rooms
clearly this appears to be the honey
room suite it's a [ __ ] room
danny is lured into the room with a
tennis ball we saw jack earlier chucking
a ball against the wall in the colorado
lounge and when jack
kisses the beautiful woman the mirror
reflection
again reveals the dark horrifying truth
and then we have an abrupt cut to danny
again
drooling the same way that the mirror
earlier with danny revealed a dark
horrifying truth a mirror again that
matched the floor design in the bathroom
evidence that is all there to shine a
light on two of the biggest wtf's of the
shining
danny's bruises and the bear costume
[ __ ] dude to suggest that danny
tragically could be that bear
it would also explain why jack refuses
to confirm the ghost that he saw in room
237 to windy
did you find anything no
nothing at all even if the hotel's evil
has corrupted jack at this point
it wouldn't make sense for him to defend
it and gaslight wendy since he was
clearly so shaken by that old woman
ghost i would argue his reaction
could be his own guilt haunting him as
he realized what he did to danny in that
room so jack tells wendy
he thinks danny gave himself the bruises
wendy suggests to take danny out of the
hotel
in this moment danny wide awake yikes he
shines to see a quick flash of red rhyme
because he knows that it's this moment
jack's feelings toward wendy
first become physically hostile and we
are reminded that jack's wrath in this
moment is linked to the moment at the
bar
because just like he looked directly
into the lens there if you go frame by
frame through him storming out of the
suite
he looks directly at us once again with
a very sinister look and then jack
is lured back into the gold room now
filled with guests in 1920s attire
and this now iconic music this is
midnight the stars in you and it's now
one of the most recognized music cues in
pop culture
toy story 4 played it to creep us out
and in ready player 1's recreation the
overlook the gold room was shot and
scored the same way
[Music]
jack gets another drink and does this
little dance just like wendy suggested
earlier on the tour
boy i bet you we could really have a
good party in this room huh and then
jack collides with the server so they
head in the bathroom a strikingly red
one modeled on the bathroom in the
biltmore hotel in arizona designed by
frank lloyd wright the server tells him
that his name is grady which raises a
red flag for jack
weren't you once the caretaker here you
uh
chopped your wife and daughter up into
little bits
and then you blew your brains out
the previous caretaker that jack is
referring to is charles grady from 10
years earlier this man is delbert grady
from the 1920s so different first name
but he does look the same as the guy
that jack saw in the newspapers so this
shines some light on the final reveal
that jack's soul
just like grady's soul is trapped inside
the overlook
but in different reincarnated forms
generation after generation
you are the caretaker
you've always been the caretaker i
should know sir
i've always been here grady reveals his
more sinister agenda warning jack that
danny had alerted halloran
so jack sabotages the radio and the snow
cat meanwhile dany screams red rum
and speaks to wendy only as tony saying
that danny has
gone away halloran makes his way to
colorado from miami he passes a wreck
with a red volkswagen beetle crushed
some have interpreted this as a middle
finger from kubrick to king since the
torrances drive a red beetle in the book
kubrick changed it to a yellow one in
the movie wendy finally discovers jack's
typed
pages all work and no play makes jack a
dull boy for international versions of
the film kubrick actually shot new takes
of the pages
translated into different languages with
a different work-related idiom from that
country like in german it was never put
off until tomorrow what can't be done
today in italian it was the man and it's
gold in its mouth and french it was
one here you go is worth more than two
you'll have it
it's the equivalent of a bird in the
hand is worth two in the bush and the
spanish it is no matter how early you
get up you cannot make the sun rise any
sooner jack surprises wendy and he
stalks her around the lounge threatening
her
danny is shining to watch this all go
down and he sees that wendy is able to
keep away from jack by walking
backwards literally danny escapes from
jack in the maze
by literally also walking backwards in
his own footsteps wendy knocks jack in
the head
he falls down the stairs and she locks
in the pantry later jack speaks to grady
through the door and mysteriously the
door unlocks
you'll give your word on that deal mr
torrence
i give you my word if we assume that all
the phenomena of the overlook can be
explained by physical logic or delusion
this is the only moment that cannot be
explained one theory for how jack could
have escaped is
danny or more specifically tony and
maybe huni is enabling jackson's sanity
throughout this process
in order to lure him into the maze so
that he'll freeze to death but the
moment
jack gets out dany writes red rum with
wendy's lipstick on the bathroom door
shouting at her until she wakes up and
sees it reflected as murder in the
mirror
it's another example of how the dark
truth of the shining is not presented in
front of us
can only be reflected in mirrors jack
axes his way into the apartment and he
taunts them through the bathroom door
little pigs let me come in
not by the hair on your chinny chin chin
then i'll
huff and i'll puff
and i'll blow your house in
[Music]
this line is inspired by the shiny novel
the characters that the bear costume and
his lover were based on
the book it was a dog costume actually
and he's worn by a guy named roger
lover of the hotel owner horace derwent
at one point
danny hearst them having sex in another
room roger screams for him to get it
up saying oh huff and i'll puff until
harry derwent's all blown
down jack axes into the bathroom and
hits us with that money line
here's johnny apparently nicholson
ad-libbed the line and kubrick didn't
watch the tonight show with johnny
carson so he had no idea what he was
referencing but then jack hears halloran
pulling up so danny hides in the kitchen
something spielberg later nodded to with
jurassic park jack jumps out from behind
a column to murder halloran halloran's
death is not in vain
because he is the one distraction that
separates jack from danny and windy
allowing them to later escape and now
that all the insanity has broken loose
gotten out there in the open
finally wendy also perceives all the
evil in the hotel hearing its voices
and seeing its demons
now i think there's enough evidence to
make it valid to interpret this as the
moment wendy perhaps puts too new
together about jack's sexual abuse of
danny or it's totally okay to just
interpret this as the backstory from the
novel that was left out from the film
windy runs into another ghost of the
bloody head
this is another line from the book
spoken by derwent to wendy and danny the
final act of the book plays out quite
differently again there's no hedge maze
there's no blood elevator but the ghosts
of the hotel play a much bigger role
there are hedge statues outside that
come to life instead we just see wendy
witnessing the lobby in classic horror
imagery
and blood gushing out of the elevator
meanwhile jack the minotaur
chases dany through the hedge maze
outside but we know danny has an
advantage we saw him specifically
spending time
playing in this maze with his mother
earlier he knows how to find its center
and his shining ability taught him that
looking and moving backwards is the road
to salvation so jack chasing him finds
that danny's footprints have just
disappeared he's lost in despair because
from his perspective
danny has just vanished into thin air
jack's insanity has consumed him trapped
him in the heart of the maze
kubrick underscores this defeat by
shooting jack's silhouetted
further and further away from the camera
with the darkness closing in
around him danny and wendy escape jack
freezes to death now before the iconic
final shot there was
actually a deleted scene set in a
hospital in which danny and wendy are
visited by mr ullman who explains that
there was no evidence of ghosts or
elevator blood anywhere but he leaves
danny with the ball that was rolled to
him outside room 237
the idea was that ullman was a kind of
ambassador for the ghostly death trap of
the overlook and that perhaps he told
jack the story of charles grady in order
to
trigger his insanity all the best people
but the scene was removed probably for
the better because instead the film
leaves us
on this slow push in on the black and
white photographs that have covered the
hotel walls throughout the film we
didn't think to look at them but now we
see the one right in the middle
the group shot jack is standing there
among the guests july 4th
1921 as grady explained to us earlier
jack has always been the caretaker his
soul
trapped inside the overlook and kubrick
has confirmed that the ballroom
photograph at the end suggests a
reincarnated version of jack
so whether or not you interpret the
shining as a story about violence
against native americans or the
holocaust or sexual abuse you cannot
deny that it is a story
about how historical violence lingers as
a weight on the future generation
and only by looking backward to embrace
those past horrors
can we escape that violence from
consuming us as well a truth that was
there the whole time
we just simply overlooked it okay thank
you for joining me in this analysis of
stanley kubrick's shining thank you for
watching
and uh i've always been new rockstars
[Music]
caretaker
[Music]
you